infinite consciousness
reverse engineering the universe
i invite you
to play
to be open
in an investigation
of the nature of reality
and to use logic
to use reason to use
deduction and to use
the intellect
to understand your truest nature
i've been serving
my friends
and other people online
by
guiding them
on this process
and through their own
realizations
through their own inquiry
through their own investigation
their own openness
their own fearlessness their own
courage their own
desire to augment their understanding
to the most true of what our nature is
they have been able to open
more and more of
that truest realization
to set in
and i invite you to do the same
in an open and playful inquiry
one of the easiest
ways to understand
what is at the end of
awakening
is infinite consciousness
by understanding what's at the end
and having it be in this
north star position
we can directly point
to it
and we can know what realization we
seek and so now i would like to
break down the questions along the way
that enable the individuation
of life
to create the inquiry
process into its nature
that creates the realizations of
the profundity of consciousness
and infinity
which then yields the direct
experience and realization of
the truest nature of reality
so first is infinity
i would like for you
to imagine
[Music]
unbounded
endless possibility
so reflect on
what it is like for something to have
no limits for it to be
completely bound less
what does the space look like
of all possibility of
endless possibility of infinite
possibility
and as you're tuning in
to that absolute unboundedness
infinite possibility i ask you the
question
when will you come to the end
of exploring it
so let that sink in
when will i come to the end
of exploring infinite
possibility
how can anything
ever come to the end of exploring
something that is unbounded
so if something unbounded is being
explored
it would never cease
it would perpetually for eternity
explore
all possibility
okay so now
let's move into the question might
we be using a universe
as a mechanism to explore
some of that infinite possibility
so might the universe
be a design that we use
a mechanism that we use
to explore some of that infinite
possibility
might the universe be one
of endless
mechanism designs that we use
to explore infinite possibility
so the design of the universe
what appears as
space-time with these individuated
conscious
agents that have biologically evolved
on these rocks that are orbiting stars
that then become self aware
and wonder why they are there
might this
universe design be but one
of infinite mechanisms
that we use to explore infinite
possibility
and so now you're exploring
the unbounded design space
there is an unbounded design space
for how to explore infinite possibility
and what we experience
as this universe design is but
one of endless possibility in
that space
of mechanisms
and it's a very beautiful one
the fractal geometry
is just awe-inspiring
and how beautiful is it to just
applaud the design of it
and how beautiful it is
so typically overlooked
is expressing gratitude
and awe for the beauty
for the design
for the mechanism to explore infinite
possibility
and besides the universe
being
one of endless mechanisms that we use to
explore infinite possibility
we can't
forget which we typically overlook
perpetually
which is how we are having this
conversation right now
why are we overlooking consciousness
why are we overlooking awareness
why are we overlooking the ability to
have a conversation
why is the universe overlooking
the ability for it to have a
conversation with
itself
let that sink in
why is the universe perpetually
overlooking ungrateful for
unaware of the profundity
of it being able to talk to itself
through consciousness
that's pretty freaking cool if you ask
me
and the more that you awaken the more
that you recognize
how unbelievably epic
this is
so ask yourself the question
how does the universe understand
comprehend
process itself
so the universe
needs to use a mechanism
to understand itself to comprehend
itself
to process itself
and so just ruminate on that for a
moment
okay what is the universe using to
understand itself
to comprehend itself to process itself
might it be us
might it be observation might it be
consciousness might it be awareness
might observation consciousness
awareness be the comprehension
tool slash mechanism
might the very thing that we perpetually
overlook
because it's so indescribable
it's so formless it's a quality
this power to know consciousness
awareness might
that which we habitually perpetually
overlook to focus on
objects and sensations and perceptions
and emotions and beliefs
and experiences
might we be so habitually and
perpetually
focused on the appearances
that we've atrophied
our ability to notice
the formless power to know
the quality that is indescribable that
is consciousness that is awareness
that is the very tool the very
mechanism that the universe
uses to comprehend understand
process itself
and at this point
if you're
experiencing
opening
into a more intimate direct
experience of what is being
shared
take a moment to pause the video
and just take some inhalations
and reflect on
that new direct experience
that is so beautiful and intimate
and so i invite you to do so right now
if that is the case
and i also invite you to feel into your
heart
also
feel into your heart
what is possible
to be unlocked for
earth
upon the direct
experience and realization of
this infinite oneness this infinite
consciousness
hmm
so now we have a greater understanding
of how the universe comprehends itself
through the mechanism of consciousness
and so we then ask the question
is observation equality
like the power to know
is it the same quality for us all
and so this is where this infinite
oneness
and this infinite consciousness becomes
very
interesting
so there's this indescribable formless
quality of the power to know
observation consciousness awareness
that were habitually overlooking
focusing on appearances
rather than the very essence
we're fixated on the expression
and when you come back to the essence
it's this formless indescribable
quality the power to know a
quality it's fascinating equality
kind of like sweetness
is equality or
wetness is a quality
awareness is a quality
an indescribable formless quality
like sweetness like wetness
is also awareness
in this
is
what has been
slightly twisted and perverted
in some of the religious traditions
but yet there are these mystic
schools within
much of the spiritual tradition
where mysticism means
the same thing that yoga means
the same thing that hypnosis means
which is becoming one
with god mysticism
yoga hinosus means becoming one with god
and so might when we
unite intimately in a divine
kiss with the indescribable
formless power to know
that is uniting
with the kingdom of god
that was there the whole time
but that we were perpetually
overlooking
and now you can see more clearly
that through
fixating our awareness
on objects and thoughts
emotions beliefs sensations perceptions
experiences
that we've atrophied our ability
to sense this indescribable
formless power to know
the kingdom of god itself
and it's okay
it's perfectly okay
that if you're 25
or 35 or 50 or 70 years old
and that there has yet to be
this very divine indescribable
kiss reuniting
with the kingdom of god with the power
to know
that was there the whole time that we
were perpetually overlooking
that it's totally okay and that it's
very beautiful that everybody
in their own time
reunites in their own unique way
reunites
it's all perfect as it is
and everyone's unique process their
unique
journey to
realizing through direct experience
the profundity of the quality
that is indescribable that is formless
that is awareness that is the power to
know
that we've been habitually overlooking
that this is all perfect and divine
in its timing for each individuation
as it is
across all universe designs
across all creation possibilities
forever and ever it's perfect
as it is all individuals unique
journeys to reunite
and upon that kiss
upon that union upon
that recognition
there's the realization
of our shared
infinite eternal being
the quality of god
has always been and will
always be
the quality of god
has always been and will always be
and tune in
to that i am
that i am
before what i am
what i am
are these costumes
and all of these concepts
but that i am
is an indescribable formless
quality that is shared
and that is god that i am
so you can tune in
as a mantra for yourself i am
reflect like a mantra
i am
i am the quality
that explores infinite possibility
i am
am try it
i am
i am the quality
that explores infinite possibility
and when you notice that more and more
of your subconscious
conditioning that has built
all of these fortifications
around your identity
that has created so much separation
that has created all of these
subconscious scripts
that are driving your life
trying to extract peace and happiness
and validation and worthiness
and money and fame
relationships substances experiences
and all of that subconscious
conditioning
all of that separation all of those ego
scripts
dissolve they are all
radically loved and accepted
exactly as they are
and they dissolve they are transcended
and what emerges
is the recognition
of the god state
the infinite oneness the infinite
consciousness through
a simple reverse
engineering of the universe you have
come to the truest
nature of reality that the sages
that the mystics and even science as
johnny come lately
have been talking about
as this indescribable formless
quality of i am
and then you radiate like the sun
the sun radiates
absolute unconditional love
light unity
purely serving planet earth
and now upon your awakening
upon your enlightenment
get it right enlightenment and sun
upon this kiss upon this union
with the god realized state
this very natural
emanation
of unconditional love light unity
of serving and shepherding the rest of
life to awaken
is so
oh
it's beautiful to see what
we've went through as a civilization
with all of our unknowing
of what the nature is and
having all those subconscious scripts
and programs around separation ego
creates so much malevolence and so much
violence
so much hatred so much war
and to be able to see that
that was our pressure cooker
that was our forcing function
it was our forcing function to recognize
the nature of infinite oneness of
infinite consciousness
of god that is a formless indescribable
quality
of the power to know that we habitually
overlook
because we fixate uncontrollably
on attributes on
appearances
and so the individual undergoes
a process of decentralizing themselves
from all of that
subconscious conditioning by radically
loving and accepting it
it dissolves and the individual
transcends it
and in doing so it unites
with god
god being the decentralized
force that is the universe
itself
and so it becomes your body the universe
becomes your body
the universe becomes you you become the
universe
you awaken to that
you empty yourself you empty yourself
of the personhood
the personhood that is
fighting for worthiness
that is fighting for validation
it's fighting to be seen
it's fighting for money and fighting for
fame
and you empty yourself of all of that
subconscious conditioning
and you liberate yourself
you liberate all of those scripts that
are subconsciously
programmed in this neural architecture
and in doing so in that liberation
opens up the space
the space of knowing yourself for
the very first time
if you feel into the grasp
that all of those subconscious scripts
have
if you just turn
your attention inward rather than
fixating on appearances and attributes
just turn your attention inward
and identify in all of those
subconscious lack beliefs
of i am not worthy
or i seek validation
i need to be seen
and just turn
the spotlight of awareness on
itself in those places of subconscious
conditioning
and as you identify them and more and
more
clearly see them
and love them and accept them radically
as they are they
dissolve you liberate yourself from them
you
transcend them and the space opens up
which is the god state it's
the sunlight
and then you come from a place of
perpetual
worthiness always already
100 worthy always
already 100 free always already
100 perfect as it is
and you come from a place that is empty
of personhood you come from a
decentralized place
of life itself of god itself
of universe itself you are
than shepherding stewarding
serving the creation awakening
to its own nature
and you do it in a non-attached way
you do it while balancing unconditional
love
with wisdom
this has been our biggest
error a very
beautiful
perfect as it is error
which is that we had
created the ignorant belief
that god was outside
and god was above we
created a dualism and that was our
biggest mistake that was our biggest
error
and so god is not
outside and above but rather god
is inside god is inside
and it's the deepest root experience
within
it is
that which is the root experience
that enables all of the appearances
so the essence enables
the expression
it's the deepest root experience within
it's pure not to
it's pure non-dual
so now you see the mistake you see the
error in creating
this ignorant dualism
so you could say that the entire purpose
of spirituality
is to close that gap
the delta
from dualism to non-duality
to dissolve more and more of the
subconscious conditioning and scripts
of the egoic separate person
via radical love and acceptance
to close the gap to reunite
with the god state that was there the
whole time
but that we were perpetually overlooking
because it is an indescribable formless
quality
of awareness of the power to know
and so when you reverse engineer
logically what the point of the universe
is
maybe producing conscious agents
that experience it
when will you come to the end of
consciousness
exploring infinite possibility
so just tapping in
again to this process of reverse
engineering
we're trying to understand
how the universe comprehends
itself how does the universe understand
itself how does the universe process
itself
might it be done through observation
through awareness through consciousness
through the indescribable formless
quality
of god the power to know
and so as you go through a process of
reverse engineering
how the universe is one
of infinite mechanism designs
to explore all possibility
and that consciousness awareness this
formless indescribable quality
of the power to know is
that which is
the experiencer the observer
the witness the explorer
the one that plays
in this infinite possibility space
using the mechanisms of
these beautiful fractal geometrical
universes as just one
style of design
as you also look at
the way that
the universe undergoes a process
of fractally across
all of these different
self similar
repeating patterns
the
super galaxy cluster looks like the
neural networks
and the hurricanes look like the
galaxies
and the romanesco broccoli looks like
the nautilus shell
looks like succulents in the golden
ratio the fibonacci
fractals and the human
is a fractal as well
the same quality
of awareness of the power to know
is across all of these humans across all
of these earths
these rocks that are orbiting stars
across all galaxies across the entire
universe
that's the fractal geometrical power
of our universe design ability
and then you explore all of the other
styles of
design for mechanisms of not only
universes but also the power to know
there's all of these different ways to
create
awareness to create the power to know
just like there's all of these different
ways to create
universes that are not rocks
orbiting stars that are not
dna encoded carbon based
four limb two-eyed vehicles
and so there's all of this infinite
possibility space with the power to know
with this formless indescribable quality
of god of awareness
and all of these styles of universe
designs
the mechanism that we use to explore
infinite possibility eternally varies
so beautifully
and will never come to the end of
exploring infinite possibility
and so i invite you into that reflective
process
might this be the most direct path to
the end of the nature of reality
might the simple inquiry about infinity
and the
simple inquiry about consciousness
might that be the most
direct path to the truest nature of
reality
and so i invite you i invite you to
openly honestly playfully
reflect and turn inward
might this revelation
might this union
this
tasting of the truest
nature might every single time
that there's more and more deepening of
this
realization by direct experience may
that
unlock this indescribable unity in
oneness
that then everything that we create
from that unity in oneness is
automatically art or science or
engineering or whatever we do comes
from a place of wholeness it comes from
a place of unity and oneness
it comes from a place of service from a
place of shepherding
from a place of stewardship of life
because we are already whole we are
already
100 full we are already the sun
the god state radiating
and so you see how at the root
experience
this is what is most upstream the more
individuations of life that turn
inward to understand this faster
the more the entire planet
and the whole universe is ignited
in its awakening
this is the most upstream solution
to everything else that is downstream
a natural byproduct of
reuniting with the kingdom of god within
with that
infinite oneness the infinite
consciousness
is that you become
a shepherd a steward
in pure service of the rest
of creation awakening so everything you
create artistically scientifically
engineering computer science
ai everything that you do
from that point on will be not from a
place of extraction
that you're still trying to get
validation trying to be seen trying to
be
worthy trying to get money and fame
for peace and happiness but instead
you're gonna come
from a place of 100 always already
worthy free perfect radiant
sunlight the god state
enlightenment awakening
infinite oneness infinite consciousness
logically deduced logically
reasoned
might we be looking in the branches
for what can only be found
in the roots
love you rumi
so remember i
am
remember i am
i am all of life
i am all of creation i am all of the
universe
i am this indescribable formless quality
the power to know
i am habitually overlooked
lured outward by appearances
by attributes
but when i remember
when i turn inward when i undergo that
divine
kiss that union
indescribable infinite oneness infinite
consciousness
opens up and i'm able to feel
that i will never ever come to the end
of my endless exploration
and that i come from a place
of serving of shepherding
in a non-attached way
creation awakening and there's nothing
better to do
than exactly that
i am
again logically deduced logically
reasoned
the end of awakening enlightenment
beautiful thank you very much hope this
brought you
immense value and assistance
guidance
because so many previously for me have
done the same
so i pass it along
i love you
thank you i would love to
know where you're at in the comments
below in the process and how i can serve
you
so drop a comment below
and share the video also
with other people that you feel like
this would really resonate with
like the video subscribe to the channel
i am
infinite consciousness
infinite oneness
love you thank you
you